okay thank you so what I'm going to talk
about is it's really work that was done
a long time ago and that's maybe a long
time we're going everybody sense rather
than just Leslie but at the time seemed
to fall on completely deaf ears maybe
it's still well I don't know but let's
give it a try so I should point out that
this is is joint work with with Magnus
born rich who isn't here and Merritt
karpinski who is so so that the main
thrust will be about counting
independent sets in hypergraphs that
we'll talk about some other stuff maybe
if I have time so ve will be a
hypergraph H the maximum degree is Delta
so the minimum eight shows will will
take as being em a lot of the people
been working in this area seem to use K
for this but M is now k so breach edge
in the hypergraph it's a subset of the
vertex set and we're assuming that the
cardinality of these sets azores at
least damn the maximum degree is the
maximum number of edges in which any
vertex falls I should say that because
there are other definitions of degree in
hypergraphs but this is perhaps the most
common an independent set is an edge
sorry set in which no age is a subset of
that
so there's no there's no a journey which
is a subset of our if I is an
independent set and will they'll megha
be the set of all independent sets in H
so so here is an independent set so
these are the edges if you look you can
see that none of them is full but if I
were to add that one this is not an
independent set because this is full
again there are many other definitions
of independent set in hyper graph but
this is the one that will be used
throughout so we could consider a simple
Markov chain on this set up which is the
global dynamics it's usually cult so the
state space is the set of all
independent sets and starting from some
independent set a transition is given by
picking a vertex in the hypergraph
uniformly at random with probability a
half we augment IT with v sorry delete
IT from v of course it may not be in
there in which case this does nothing
with probability half we set V we add V
to RIT so prime T so if I prime T is
indeed an independent set which because
it may not be then I t plus 1 will be I
prime T otherwise we do nothing and
continue so it's fairly clear that this
is irreducible because we could go from
any independent set to any other
independent sets a through the empty
independent set it's a periodic well
that's fairly easy to see because there
are a lot of moves that do nothing and
it's symmetric because
we do both these things with probability
half so the stationary distribution is
uniform on Omega that is the the
probability that we're in any
independent set after long enough is
about 1 over the size of the set Omega
so the question is of course the pie I
are used to mean the the steady state
distribution even though here it will
always be just 1 over Omega so how big
do we need to make tea to get close
enough to uniform one approach to
bounding convergence time is to use
coupling so coupling is a random process
on Omega cross Omega such that
marginally both IT and JD of faithful
copies of N and we usually measure
convergence in this setting by total
variation distance which is sort of half
the l1 norm of the difference between
the distribution we have at time T and
the equilibrium distribution pi so
friggin DS design the coupling so the IT
and JT quickly become close then we have
this very old lemma which says that if
JT was to start in the stationary
distribution then the variation distance
is at most apology the IT is not equal
to j t so of course we don't know what
the stationary where we can't sample
from the stationary distribution so JT
is a code of notional copy of the
process whereas i t is the one that
we're actually interested in ok
so half coupling is a way of trying to
make a coupling a bit easier and when
it's applicable it gives a simple way to
devise a suitable coupling so we take
any metric on only girl and suppose s is
a subset to roam across some girls such
that for all IJ you know we could cross
Omega there is a path of transitions
from I to J I think that should be s
cross s but that should be yes sorry
there's a path of transitions from i to
j for which each of these is in s and
I'll admit it's okay because it's it's
like bonus so the distance is the
distance between successive ones so so
this is a path along which the distances
are kind of preserved by the steps and
then we need only define the coupling
four pairs in s and we extend the
coupling to any pair via shortest paths
in s so these this will become a
shortest path
so the theorem that drives this is from
paper with rust bubbly 97 that if we can
show that for all pairs in s the
expected distance goes down in one step
there's some betta less than 1 such that
the expected distance that the next step
is less than equal to be 2 times the
distance at this step then the mixing
time which is the time taken for the
variation distance to become less than
epsilon is this so it's log D of R
epsilon over 1 minus beta where D is the
maximum distance between any pair of
states in this metric so if we can make
a suitable choice of s and D it greatly
simplifies both the definition and the
analysis of a coupling so I'll take a
stupid example but it's one that shows
how the method works which is
independent sets in graphs so this is a
case M equals two of the hypergraph
independent set problem we'll just take
d to be hamming distance so it's the
number of vertices in which the the two
copies will differ and s will just be
the set of pairs at distance one and
we'll use the identity coupling that is
we just perform the same move in both
shane's let suppose sir I T is JT with W
removed by symmetry that's enough so
which transitions change the distance so
if M picks a neighbor of W and tries to
insert itself it could be rejected in JT
but accepted in IT that as if no other
neighbors V is occupied which we have to
assume is the worst case so this is the
bad
thing that can happen but the good thing
is that we might actually pick W in
which case it can be accepted in both
chains so if we do the analysis of how
the distance changes it started out as
one if we chose w it was decreased by 1
over N but if we chose some neighbor of
W which we would do with property Delta
of rain then the distance would increase
by a half a half because we only did the
thing with probability half so that's
that a simple path coupling analysis so
what do we get so we've got the expected
distance is the distance it started from
which was 1 times this factor so this
beta is 2n plus Delta minus 2 over 2 n
so this thing really only works if
Delta's strictly less than two ok which
it's not really an astounding result but
if it if Delta was less than 2 then
you've got this mixing time right so
you'd be in good shape so obviously this
doesn't yield anything of interest but
their various ways we can go with this
idea I mean you can change the chain you
can change the metric or you can change
the coupling and that all of those
sometimes give you something better so
if we tune this up a bit better then we
can get down to less than equal to 4 and
that was first done by lubing Vigoda 99
using a kind of bare hands coupling
argument and then using this argument by
myself and Catherine greenhill in two
thousand
so this gives an f press for counting
independent sets in graphs on the other
hand with Allan Friesen mark gem we
showed that there is no F press when
Delta's at least 25
so there's been a lot of stuff done on
independent sets in graphs was much of
what she heard about here White's gave a
polynomial time algorithm for
approximately counting independent sets
and graphs when Delta's legend grew five
using an entirely different approach I
was surprised to find out that nobody
actually knows what the exponent in this
algorithm is he says it's polynomial
time and you could deduce it from what's
in the paper but nobody's willing to
give me a guess of what those ? should
be I think certainly if you know it's
more than two but how much more than two
I don't know so so what this does it
uses a tree representation we've heard a
little bit about this here already and
the depth of the tree is bounded because
you have this correlation decay in the
system so this algorithm was a major
achievement because it matched the
conjecture which was given in the paper
with fries mark Jairam that the answer
was that you could only do up to five
and then six was going to be difficult
but the other remarkable thing about
this was that it's deterministic so
everything up to here had been
randomized and in fact there was a
belief growing that that you had to have
randomization to do this certainly if
the problem started out as a number P
complete exact counting problem that's
on the other side Alan sly dramatically
improved the construction that that I'd
had with mark and Alan and showed that
there's no F prize when Delta's at least
six so closing the bound on the other
side
and these results have been generalized
to local to spin systems which referred
a bit about but they don't seem to
generalize so easily to hypergraphs and
or more than two spins so this these
results produce this feeling that that
this kind of markov chain approach was
the wrong way to go and that the right
way was to go was to use so correlation
decay but that doesn't really seem to be
true as we will see so as we use path
coupling on hypergraphs and if using the
identity coupling the same analysis
applies and we take the same kind of
coupling so here we've got the one
that's different and the there are Delta
edges surrounding it and there's Delta
vertices that might be inserted into JT
but not into I T so we would still end
up requiring delta less than or equal to
two I say less than or equal to because
the Equality cases is actually still
good for us but
so how might we do better so if we look
at what the the bad configuration is
it's it's this right so we've got Delta
edges that are almost full and we think
we might add one of these next in which
case it would go wrong and we'd increase
the distance so there are Delta bad
vertices in one step we're obviously
more likely to hit one of those than we
are to hit W so these are the bad
vertices you there's three times as much
chance of hitting one of those as
hitting this but if we look at this
we're far more likely to hit one of
these guys right if we do then things
actually get better for us so we might
hit that one then we might hit that one
and that one that one now we hit this
guy that started out being bad and he
doesn't do us any harm right so
so what we see is that there are bad
configurations who don't expect any
immediate contraction in distance but
it's likely that we'll move to a better
configuration before the distance
changes so if we first tried to use this
argument with what was called stopping
times so what we did was to just run the
process and try and look what happened
until you know that we got the bad event
that the distance increased so this was
originally used by myself Katherine
Greenhill Leslie girl bookmark Jairam
and Mike mitts and Mac in 2001 and we
obtained some small improvement for the
graph coloring Markov chain they've been
later improvements this method by Hazen
Vigoda and paper with language bored
rich in America pit ski so
so how could we modify the metric so we
could penalize the bad configure
information in the metric so that
movement towards better configurations
now results in contraction so knocking
out those vertices is actually going to
be doing us some good rather than just
doing nothing so we have to balance this
of course with weaker contraction on the
good configurations which have some
probability becoming bad and of course
we get an increase in the maximum
distance between any pair of states I
won't dwell too much on these things but
so the intuition is that each pair of
states that are one apart has some
contraction which is the expected value
of the next distance divided by the
distance now so we identify the critical
configurations which have got expected
contraction alpha 0 and we increase the
distance for those so that they're
expected contraction reduces but the
expected contraction of their neighbors
increases we stop when these balance
this will give us some newer set of
critical configurations and we just
repeat for those okay so
so what are the bad configurations well
we said before if we take IT and JT at
distance one with IT is JT + w then the
bad set of edges are these things where
he has i occupied vertices will define
the seti i and the bad configuration is
that the set of of edges with n minus 2
occupied vertices is delta because
there's this guy which we're kind of
ignoring so if there's only one that's
not occupied this is bad
how bad is the configuration it's
badness increases with a number of
occupied vertices so suppose edge e I
and engineer that's got I occupy
vertices as badness CI and the CI will
be a non decreasing set of constants and
we'll assume that each age containing w
contributes independently to the badness
of the configuration that by which I
mean we'll just add up so our new metric
will be the sum from I equals 0 to n
minus 2 of CI times e I and without loss
of generality will assume that the last
one is one doesn't really matter what we
chose it to be but it would all come out
in the wash but one seems to my sensible
choice and for convenience will suppose
that C minus one is the same as C naught
and CM minus one is Delta plus one so
what can happen if w is chosen then the
distance decreases by this okay because
the two things are now the same so the
contribution to the expected change is
minus that times the probability that we
chose it which is basically one over n
which I've some reason best notam itself
written as 2 over 2 it if we insert a
vertex then we do increase the distance
by CI plus 1 minus CI for each edge in
the eye that contains V so this holds
for I is n minus 2 since we chose C n
minus 1 to be this so the contribution
of all the insertions is 1 over 2 and
because we only did it with property a
half times the increase times the
maximum number of edges that could have
affected
we delete a vertex then we decrease the
distance by the same amount for each of
these edges and this holds also for
items not by the choice of C minus 1 so
the contribution for all the deletions
is this so we get an eye here rather
than in we had feared before so so this
is going to actually decrease the
distance so what is the actual expected
change in distance it's this complicated
thing here so it's if i multiply through
by 2n its minus 2 times the the good
case if you like Plus this from what
would seem to be the bad places but we
also get this so some of the bad things
have now become good and this is the
case where we didn't hit anything that
was at all dangerous which we saw in the
example so if you if you work this out
it comes to this what we want is the
expected value of dt plus 1 minus DT is
less than equal to minus gamma for all
configurations but in some positive
gamma
so what we want the solution to is is
this which is the right hand side what
we saw before subject to these being non
decreasing and the constraints that we
put on them there so this gives us a set
of linear inequalities we can check the
conditions on this and find out for
which M and Delta we have delta greater
than gamma greater than zero so you can
see it effectively we need to solve a
linear program to optimize gamma subject
to these inequalities so in the first
workshop Chris Moore presented a similar
kind of application of path coupling to
moving around hard disks in the plane
where he again produced a linear program
which he had to optimize to design the
best metric so seems to be quite closely
related to this
so what is the optimal solution to that
linear program so it turns out to be
this rather horrible quantity but the
important thing is this got this M minus
Delta minus 2 and you can see fairly
easily that this is positive for M
greater equal to Delta plus 2 it needs
em at least five but that's a not really
too much importance here and when we're
talking about to be large edge size so
we have contraction and therefore rapid
mixing of a min bigger n log n time
whenever n is at least the max of Delta
plus 2 and five so it might be possible
to improve this so we didn't at the time
because nobody seemed to be interested
so we just left it there and moved on so
in the meantime though there's been some
other work on this so look at what other
work was done in the Diane Greenhill
paper on independent sets and graphs it
actually shows rapid mixing for
hypergraphs with M equals 3 and delta
equals 3 now you might think that should
be aim at least three in delta equals
three but it isn't in fact if you look
at the paper it is exactly that right
that was the case we could do
and the first attempt we had it this the
the stopping time gave rapid mixing only
for M greater includes two Delta plus
one but we also showed that there is no
F press if Delta's at least 694 times 2
to the n plus 1 over 2 so so this is
something times 2 to the M over 2 okay
so that's in that paper and more
recently the you and lil gave an FP test
that's using the correlation decay
method for all m at least 2 and delta
less negative 5 so this is this is
really like Weitz's result basically and
even more recently these people berserk
over galanis goldberg grow and stefan
coverage but there is an FP tears for am
at least three and delta equal six also
he's in correlation to k that's a very
tight result that seems to be optimal
they also show that there is an FP task
for m at least 1.66 delta using
correlation decay now you can see that
this this is actually worse than the
result you've just seen okay so
correlation decay is not the magic
bullet for slaying all these kind of
problems unfortunately and so they also
improve the hardness to 22 to the M over
2 inches you can see quite a lot less
than this
but very recently at this this meeting
Herman and Jang have announced an F
press when Delta's less than or equal to
some constant whose value I don't know x
2 to the M over 2 over m squared so this
this is quite seems quite a good result
because it sort of matches these upper
bounds to some extent and in fact it's
proves something that we had thought
about this problem which was that it was
sort of M equals Delta was kind of the
close to Delta was where things went
wrong so this is a very long way from
this so-called diagonal and but notice
that
this doesn't completely settle the
problem I mean this is a long way from
doing that because even if this C is 1 2
to the M over 2 over m squared is only
better than n plus 2 if defends at least
30 right so so it doesn't cover any of
the small cases but nonetheless it's a
very interesting result and we hope to
hear something about it this week as I
understand it the technique is is is
more related to the Markov chain
approach than it is to the correlation
decay but know completely what it's
about so ok so just to spend the last 10
minutes or so so we did look at some
other problems and we looked at coloring
hypergraphs q coloring so the history of
this is that for m equals two graphs
rapid mixing for Q at least two Delta
was shown a long ago by Mark jerem in
1994 using his kind of bare hands
coupling and it was improved to Q bigger
than 11 Delta over six using a
complicated path coupling by Eric de
Gelder in 2004 general graphs this this
is still the best thing that's known
after 16 years nobody's improved this
result there are there are there are
better things known if you assume
something about the structure of the
graph right like the girth in particular
but in general this is the best that's
know
so we looked at this and it turns out
that if ends at least four it's trivial
to get Q bigger than Delta as so this
seems this seems to be very easy and
probably it should be improved from
there but we didn't we we stopped
because it seemed such an easy without
and we couldn't see and what we could do
at the time to improve it so the only
case thats it was left was m equals
three so using the method here we could
show that hyper graph coloring mixes
rapidly of queues at least 3 over 2
Delta plus 1 and this improved an
argument that was in the previous paper
which was 1.65 Delta and required that
Delta be quite large so how does
correlation decay manage with this well
not really very well so gar malachim
cats gabar f pete has in fact for list
coloring when q is at least 2.84 3 delta
and it was improved for graph coloring
by LuAnn year in 2013 who gave 2.58 1
Delta but notice that both of these are
worse than than dirhams result in 1994
so it seems that correlation decay is
not necessarily the right way to go if
you go away from to spin systems on
graphs
and I've just sketched since I have a
few minutes left wow this is done for EM
equals 3 so we identify four classes
which are defined like this so so we've
got two copies that differ in one vertex
will say the two colors are R&B and the
other color would say BG green and these
are the dangerous sets if you like in
decreasing order and this is what
happens if we immediately going to get
something going wrong so it's where the
odds and bees are the kind of things are
going to go wrong g we can just do what
we like so get these four sets and we
use the same idea of defining a metric
which depends on the size of these sets
and use the same kind of thing and this
time we get to a similar kind of that's
even more horrible expression which this
is the original good case these contain
a mixture of good and bad and that's
what happens for e 1 2 & 2 e 2 e 3
before
and if we set C 1 equals 1 we get these
values for c2 c3 and c4 and this gives
us that the expected value decreases
whenever we have this gamma less than 1
essentially I suppose so this is the
so if we work out what it is cubes got
to be at least this horrible expression
which actually works out that Q's got to
release 3 over 2 Delta plus 1 rounded up
and that's basically it so
we did one other thing in this which is
not quite the same flavor but we looked
at coloring bipartite graphs and whether
we could improve the golders but this is
really just looking for something that
would work so we use a different
dynamics which is the scan dynamics
where you just recolor the sides of the
bio tissue partition alternately and we
use this heat bath recoloring that's we
select an available color at random from
the set of available colors for each
vertex you can translate this into rapid
mixing for the global dynamics notice
that we can do all this independently
because all we're looking at as the
other side of the graph and so if you
look at it the bad thing that can happen
is you choose a particular one of the
available colors that is the one that's
different so we define this matrix which
waits the thing down by 1 over the size
of the available that should be yeah
it's another number the Sun a is both a
set and a number here so
so this is the distance and if we use
path coupling just simple path coupling
with this it gives rapid mixing if Q's
bigger than some function of Delta this
function tends to 1.76 for Delta Delta
tends to infinity so this improves be
gold is 11 dealt over 6 which is about
1.8 34 Delta so for Delta at least 14
it's at least as good and if Delta's
bigger than 31 it's better that's this
is all quite weak resulting we didn't
take it any further we could probably
improve this by using some of the kind
of optimization that you saw in the
other two but it just shows that this
this idea is is worth thinking about
still and that coupling is not
completely dead
question nobody's going to leap to the
defense of correlation decay things